hi it's a new day it's a new dawn
and it's a new opportunity to play pogo
stuck
i actually have made progress i got back
to the point
where i was which was among the flowers
and i don't know where to go from here
but it seems like people are going up
and then using this as a platform to
launch
farther to the left the flowers seem to
flow
up and to the left and those people just
didn't come back down so i'm assuming
that's where i'm supposed to go
so that's where i intend to go
just gonna start slow ah
i think i see a platform up there yeah
okay so that's
this this is super tricky this is super
tricky
this is like very little oh there's like
very little room to actually bounce off
of
without going at such a steep angle that
you'll end up falling off
like this like this like this like this
okay
do you really gotta hit that gap oh my
god you do don't you
oh my god oh my god okay you gotta hit
that gap
yeah yeah yeah one more one more one
more
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
where am i no
it's fine it's not too bad this isn't
too bad all i got to do is get enough
speed
uh you know i should stop trying to flip
up
on the wall just use the wall one more
yes here we go okay that didn't work
so i need one more after that i got to
go really high up
here we go yes yes ah
oh my god yes yes holy crap
oh my god i made it this is progress the
birds
the flowers but whatever the hell the
things i'm on are
are these what are these i don't think
these are flowers
these don't qualify as flowers grapes
great oh no that's how do you expect to
make that jump
how do you expect to make that jump oh
no oh no oh no oh no oh no
oh through the gap ah crap
if if you know if my guy didn't have
such a rotund body
this wouldn't be nearly as difficult as
it is if he just slimmed down a little
bit
then i'd be able to not bounce off the
walls like a beach ball
but unfortunately this is the body i was
given
so i have to make do oh my god i flipped
in there i did not mean to flip in there
flipping in there was a bad idea
flipping in there was a bad choice but
it worked out but that doesn't mean that
it was good
okay here we go nope almost
here we go boom easy okay
easy easy easy oh oh yeah
oh yeah oh oh yeah easy
easy oh my god easy oh my god
okay so i think i know what it wants me
to do
it wants me to bounce off of this flower
here onto that platform in the bottom
left
and then boost up to the left somewhere
i'm just going to watch what this person
does first
yes yes exactly exactly
somewhere to the left not 100 sure where
but somewhere to the left who knows
where i don't okay i definitely do not
but that doesn't matter it doesn't
matter
all i gotta do is do what
okay all i gotta do is do whatever is
required of me okay
yes where am i going oh my god
that's such a small
angle oh i'm up
oh boy here we go oh yes i love it
i love it i oh i don't love it i don't
love it
ah crap that's fine i'd rather be
i'd rather be here than much farther
back which is what could happen
at the drop of a hat if i have to go
back to the beginning i'm deleting the
game
no no no no i'm going to delete you i
will delete you
i will delete you
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you what
the flying [ __ ] oh you [ __ ]
oh you [ __ ] here we go
ah shoot
oh shoot there we go
oh love it you love to see it you love
to see it
here we go here we go here we go here we
go this is it is it is oh
damn it
oh [ __ ] oh no oh no no no no i'm losing
it i'm losing it i'm
losing no god oh my god no no no please
please please please no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no
no
oh no no oh my god
oh my no oh my god okay
minor setbacks minor setbacks
not major setbacks minor setbacks
that's not a boost i don't know why no
god
damn you there we go boosting
oh my god oh my god no
oh my god stop
it's fine so long as i don't let it get
to me
it's
no no no no
oh the [ __ ] slip of all things
i hate this slip the most the slip is
no no
oh my oh my
if i can't see it it can't hurt me and
that's
all this game does is hurt me that's all
this game does
is hurt me this game just hurts
there's no joy there's no joy in this
game
there's no joy there's only pain there's
only pain it should be criminal
it should be it should be criminal to
cause this much misery
this should be criminal the people
should be held accountable for this
ah and of course yep through the gap
perfectly slotted actually
you know perfectly slotted through the
gap literally couldn't have been more
perfect that was pixel perfect
perfection
of failure
and no boost no boost through the
through thread it thread it baby
perfectly threaded oh my god it couldn't
be more perfect
but it just couldn't it literally could
not be more perfect
to [ __ ] me it literally perfectly [ __ ]
me
every time it's so like i can be
imprecise
but my mistakes are always
perfect like to the frame to the pixel
exactly what i don't need it's
just incredible what it will do
to prevent me from accomplishing
my goals oh
wow that was new and again
perfect
oh no oh no no no no no
oh my god oh my god how did i do that
i don't even know how i did that look i
don't understand a lot about this game
but i'll take
uh a blessing when i can you know
i'll take it uh [ __ ] i'll take it you
know
i won't question it it decided to be
nice for once in its life
and it gave it to me and that's all
there is
oh boy oh no no no no here i go there we
go there we go
thread the needle yes yes yeah ah
[Music]
oh why did i do that oh god why did i do
that oh god why
why oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god
oh god i'm going for whatever this is i
got a big head
this is i'd rather be up there than have
a big head by the way
the big head's going to throw me off i
can already oh
[ __ ] off
no what oh my god the big head is gonna
throw me off i don't want the big head
the big head is a customization you know
i'm against customization game
you know this about me why would you
curse me with this
i do not like the big head oh my [ __ ]
god
oh my [ __ ] god
no god i [ __ ] hate the big head i
hate it i hate it so much i
cannot describe how much i hate this
[ __ ] head
i hate this [ __ ] head i hate it where
is it get the
[ __ ] rid of it get the [ __ ] out of here
oh my god [ __ ] off [ __ ] off [ __ ] off
[ __ ] off
[ __ ] off give me default where the [ __ ]
is default
[ __ ] off
oh no no no no oh my god yes
second chances were made for this
oh my god god damn it
where am i going i don't even know
anymore
why was that not a boost why would that
not have been a boost
oh my [ __ ] god oh my god here we go
this is it this is [ __ ] it this is
[ __ ] it boys i'm gonna delete the
game i'm gonna delete the game i'm gonna
delete the game
this is [ __ ] it ladies and gentlemen
this is the end of all things
this is this is hell this is hell oh my
[ __ ] god
there we go trying to flip on that last
one i think is a mistake
i was already up and beyond this point
so long ago
so many moons ago seems like a far off
time now
a time that doesn't exist anymore
because why would it
it was only a dream oh my god
oh my god it was only a dream i'll never
be among the flowers again
i know this i accept this now i see it
for what it truly is
this is my punishment for even trying
what are you doing get your
gun out of here why do you think that's
okay
what makes you think that's okay to do
okay oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] off
yes yes i am back here
finally i'm just back here this is
i'm i'm not even as far as i once was
but i'm back here
and this causes me great joy this is an
incredible day this is a wonderful day
what the hell was oh what the hell
was that what happened
what what happened what happened
i'm oh no no no no no no oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god no
what happened i don't understand what
happened what just
happened what just happened
oh my god and oh my [ __ ] god oh my
[ __ ] god
[Music]
why was my body wait stop hold on a
second what the [ __ ]
my body was clipped through my body was
clipped through the ground
and i was jumping fine what was that
what
what was that about game because every
time i hit a wall
i bounce off like a beach ball but no
then
you decided that it would be okay oh my
god
oh my [ __ ]
oh no no no no yep yep there it goes
oh my [ __ ] oh my oh
oh my god oh my god
no god [ __ ] off
it's right there i'm i get right there
i get right [ __ ] there it's always
there
right at the least opportune time
what the hell through the gap
thread it just [ __ ] thread it yeah
that's oh my god i know i shouldn't even
be surprised anymore
that this game wants to dick with me and
i i
really wonder if there's anyone out
there that even
doubts that the that was my fault that
even doubts that this game
is intentionally built to dick with
people
there that's it's clear it's so clear
when i say tomorrow i mean
[ __ ] tomorrow
oh my god just [ __ ] give me the boost
the game should be able to see what i'm
trying to do and just give it to me
just [ __ ] give it to me
uh i'm done angel in the sky
[ __ ] just [ __ ]
yes no yes okay i'm here again hey
look we're back where we
we're back where we started why is
everyone here
this is hell just go away everybody else
just leave me alone
i do not know how to turn it on to
single player
i don't know i don't know
oh my god it was about to rocket me off
this platform
oh no
oh no uh uh
no no
not again i can't do it again i can't i
literally can't please
i can't go back i literally can't
i will delete the game if i have to go
back
i swear i will delete the game it's like
this game wants to be uninstalled you
know
it really does you know it really wants
to
i think the developers must make money
for every time
someone uninstalls their game i think
that it that that
must be that's the only understanding
that i have for the
motivation behind even making this is
there
they must be getting something out of it
right they might they must get
some kind of jollies off of this right
okay here we go here we go
oh my god stop stop stop stop
stop you were through you were through
oh my god oh my god stop [ __ ] stop
[Music]
don't do it oh what the hell
that was a funky maneuver i liked it
kind of okay this is it
[ __ ]
[Music]
just [ __ ] let me up there oh no
no no no no
no if everyone could go away
i don't know how to make people go away
how do i make people go away just go
away i'm trying to see
i can't see with your [ __ ] beams oh
no
oh my god if i can make any sort of
progress
if i just stay nice and calm what i need
to do is i need to go up here and then
bounce back to the platform and then go
up
and bounce back too far too far too far
too far and then up
yes and then bounce back it's about
going back and forth
and trying to build the moment the same
as the next section
might i add same as the next section you
know it's it's about building up
momentum
got to keep the momentum going if you
lose it
then you lose your mind and then you die
no that was dumb why would i do that
where am i going
now where am i going i don't know here
we go
why would i do that why do i keep trying
to do that oh my god never mind
that's why it works perfectly i love it
and it's perfect
it never had any flaws my plant no stop
do not rocket me out of here this is
safety this is among the flowers
this is where i belong this is where
i've always
was meant to be
yes perfect in every way perfect and no
perfect in every way we're back up here
this is good this is a good thing this
is a great thing actually
all right
i think i think you need to get even
higher than that i think you need to
reach
up a little bit higher because i
remember the the
the lip is real lippy
uh it's real lippy
here this is it nope nope what was that
i have no idea i have no idea what that
was but that wasn't what i was supposed
to do oh [ __ ] off
there we go here we go here we go here
we go nope god
[ __ ] damn it oh my god
nope this is not it not the one
here we go yes
oh my god
thank you everybody so much for watching
oh my god thank you everybody so much
for watching thank you everybody so much
for watching
oh thank you everybody so much for
watching my name is markiplier subscribe
please do it
now it's almost too late you're almost
out of time don't run out of time
don't run out of time to ring the bell
don't and as always
i will see you in the next video
[Music]
bye-bye
you